what's up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu i'm your host warren
thompson and today we have some news
that i know everybody loves and waits
for and that is spider-man news coming
from one of the sources that gave us a
lot of information about spider-man no
way home before the movie came out and
once the movie came out of course it was
all confirmed to be true also i did a
video i think last week talking about
sony and maybe their lack of plan for
their own spider-man universe it looks
like they might actually have a plan but
we'll talk about that as well in this
video but let's dive into the latest
spider-man report right now and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so today's report
is coming from daniel rbk i'm sure if
you kept up with spider-man no way home
all of the leaks all the rumors
everything that was going around you
know who he is and he did a video on his
youtube channel recently talking about
everything that he's heard so far about
andrew garfield and toby mcguire
returning for future spider-man projects
in fact the title of his video was
spider-man future projects with andrew
garfield now he starts off by saying
that obviously marvel studios and sony
found massive success with spider-man no
way home and the other two spider-man
returning and due to the success they
are obviously open to them returning for
future spider-man projects but daniel
rpk specifically states that what he has
heard coming straight from him is that
toby and andrew will indeed return toby
and andrew seem more than happy to come
back for spider-man no way home and in
some of the behind-the-scenes videos and
interview videos toby even said he's
kind of up for anything so this doesn't
come as that big of a surprise and
daniel actually talks a little bit more
about what he heard and we're definitely
going to dive into that but first a big
thank you to mech arena for sponsoring
today's video mecca arena is the perfect
shooter for those who love super fast
and super intense gameplay but don't
have time like they used to to play
games with mech arena i can play 2-3
matches in under 10 minutes on my phone
and still have a fun time now when i say
this game is fast paced i mean it is
action-packed start to finish and you
can finish a game in 5 minutes because
that's what the game is actually built
for built for fast action tactics and
constant encounters with other mechs and
the maps for each gameplay are actually
designed to have you running into the
enemy a lot mecha arena is perfect for
you if you love fast action gameplay
like this but you don't have a ton of
time to play games anymore and now is a
great time to download mecarina because
this month they have special easter and
golden week events all you actually have
to do is participate to get your hands
on new weapons amazing new skins and
much more this rewards pack is worth 45
dollars and the prizes get bigger and
bigger it's completely free to play on
android and ios right now and you can
use my personal link or scan my qr code
to get bonuses worth forty five dollars
we're talking about one steel reaper
skin 500 acorns and 70 000 credits to
help kick start your game
so daniel goes on to state that
something is in the works right now
something with either andrew or toby or
perhaps even both now he says that it's
not concrete at this point meaning he
doesn't really know what it's going to
be he says he doesn't know if it's going
to be a quick little cameo and perhaps
the multiverse so maybe a cameo in
multiverse of madness like we've been
hearing for some time now although we
haven't really heard much about toby in
multiverse of madness recently he still
very well could appear in the film so
daniel says it could be a quick cameo in
a multiverse movie or another movie or
it could be a full blown out spider-man
4 or tasm 3. and obviously i think this
is what people would want the most they
would want another full movie with
andrew garfield with toby maguire or
perhaps both of them or even bring tom
holland back as well and the three of
them be in a movie together although i
did hear a rumor not too long ago that
was talking about maybe a movie with
andrew garfield and toby just the two of
them together going kind of across the
multiverse i don't know if there's any
legitimacy to that rumor at all but that
is actually a movie that i really
wouldn't mind seeing i think it would be
pretty funny and pretty cool but right
now it looks like we have a few
different options of what could happen
with toby and andrew and it does seem
like they are returning sony wants it
plus andrew and toby probably want it as
well in fact andrew garfield was
recently asked about the amazing
spider-man 3 and if it was going to be
made and this is what he said no update
from me no one's going to believe me
anything i say ever again and that's my
problem and that's true he went around
for i think you know almost a year and a
half talking about how he wasn't the
werewolf and he's not in spider-man
knowing home and then of course he was
and of course that's not his fault no
one blames him for that that's what he
had to do but let's just put it this way
if tasm 3 is going to be made he's
definitely not going to be the one
that's going to tell us it's being made
but check out this very interesting news
this is coming from morbius director
daniel espinoza and it's about the
post-credits scenes in morbius and i
won't really spoil anything but let's
just say it's heavily implied that
spider-man has a future in sony's
spider-man universe i recently said that
thanks to the post-credits scenes for
morbius i'm not really sure that sony
has any type of plan for spider-man i
think they might have an idea of what
they want to do but they're kind of just
winging it right now however it appears
based off of what daniel espinoza said
that maybe they do here's what he said
in an interview with total film he sat
down to talk about the future of morbius
especially about the post-credits scene
kind of teasing the sinister six to
maybe go up against spider-man and
here's what he said i think that the
future is very exciting and i think that
the plans that sony has in very closed
rooms that i'm not really allowed to
attend or the small snippets i've heard
fills me with joy but if i said anything
they would shoot me on the spot so this
actually sounds pretty decent he says
that sony has a very very tight team
working on the future of the spiderverse
essentially but what's really
interesting is he says that he's not
allowed in that closed door he's not
allowed to hear what that team is
working on even though he just worked on
a film that exists in the spider-man
universe so i'm starting to think that
maybe just morbius unfortunately had to
suffer with big changes made to it
because of the delay it was delayed over
two years and a lot happened in those
two years including spider-man no way
home so sony's plans probably changed
and stuff got cut from morbius and the
film kind of just took a hit
unfortunately the good news is is that
it does look like sony has somewhat of a
plan and they're being very secretive
about that which is good and also pretty
expected especially after spider-man no
way home i mean we all knew about toby
and andrew being in the film basically
two years before it came out so the fact
that daniel espinoza the director of
morbius a movie in their spider-man
universe wasn't allowed in this tiny
closed door this tiny room of people who
knows what the future has in store for
the spider-verse means that they really
are trying to do everything they can to
keep everything a secret even though we
are hearing that toby and andrew are
most likely to return either for cameos
or for movies maybe spider-man 4 maybe
tasm 3. but here's my question to you
spider-man fans if this does happen if
there perhaps is a spider-man 4 that's
going to be made if there's going to be
a tasm 3 that's going to be made would
you want to know about it would you like
it to be like spider-man no way home
where we find a lot of leaks out
beforehand and we know a good majority
of big surprising things that are going
to happen or would you like to remain in
the dark the big debate after spider-man
know my home was would you have enjoyed
spider-man knowing home more if you had
no idea that toby and andrew were going
to appear in the movie or did knowing
that they were going to appear in the
movie actually make you even more
excited for the film and did that make
you enjoy the film even more i'm very
curious to hear what everybody has to
say about this one because to me the
fact that i kind of knew that toby and
andrew were going to be in the movie
made me even more excited for it because
you never know 100 because i never
admitted it however i do think i would
like some type of confirmation that
spider-man 4 is going to be made or the
amazing spider-man 3 is going to be made
i don't need to know the entire movie i
just would like a confirmation that it's
going to happen and it looks like that
is in our favor according to daniel
richman sony is talking about that right
now they have things in plan and
hopefully this secret plan that sony has
for their spider-man universe will be
revealed soon but let me know what you
think about all of this news in the
comments down below and would you choose
a spider-man 4 movie with tobey maguire
or would you choose a the amazing
spider-man 3 movie with andrew garfield
if you had to choose one let me know
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest marvel news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof